what's up guys this is eric griffin and
i want to give a big
shout out to helix sleep take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to the mattress that will give you
the best
sleep of your life find your perfect
mattress at helix helixsleep.com
alright let's do it
all right ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to
another episode of your favorite podcast
you know their names
all right welcome back uh uh what is it
2021 even though it still feel like 20
20 because the same stuff is going on
but
we're here trucking along still bringing
you the content what else can we do but
to keep living and keep moving forward
so
here we are once again riffing with
griffin i'm here for you
and i'm going to talk about a number of
things but it's just you know
another regular riffing with griffin
solo i'm in my new
new old look it's still the old looking
but it's a new
studio setup but everybody just welcome
back to
[Music]
all right
sing it back down i gotta work on the
volume
control right got my candle from the
hangover candle company and they sent me
a new one i love that smell so
shout out to them got my candles up i
broke one of my damn pictures in the
mood
so that's all messed up for you people
that are looking on youtube
i've been doing live episodes this one
isn't i didn't do this one live so it is
what it is
but welcome back to riffing with griffin
i'm here for you um when i try to work
on my
i got all these like noises going on
with myself you know what it is i got
i know i got like a sinus issue i need
to go get that what is it whatever that
surgery is called your deviated septum
i need to go fix that i drank some water
before i started so maybe
and i just get into it and then i i have
these like old man noises and i'm trying
to work on it because people send me
messages
yo dude you do this thing with your
mouth and i can hear it every time when
the punk ass it drives me crazy you know
or somebody will send me a message about
something else but
anyway happy 2021 guys uh we're here we
did it
you know i'm not gonna do like some
recap you know it's like a stigerian
review or nothing like that because it's
like whatever you know i just feel like
2020 is like
you know it's still here the stuff that
is happening
is still going on like the coronavirus
the pandemic's not going to be like well
you know it's a new year so let's
let's get out of here and let's start
the whole thing over again and give
everybody a break it's not going to work
like that
everything's still going to be just as
shitty as it was before so here we are
you know what i mean i mean that's the
tough part about it is like you know we
had these
we had the holidays you know i don't
know how you guys felt about it but for
me it was just kind of like
very low-key very chill it was hard to
do i already have trouble with holidays
right now anyway because my mom
doesn't understand that it's the
holidays the way she did before
like it's like christmas is just another
day even though she goes through the
motions so she go oh yeah merry
christmas but i know it's
not the same you know so that's tough to
deal with
for all those people out there who have
uh family parents that are dealing with
dementia grandparents or whatever you
know it's tough
you know i mean it's tough tough thing
so i'm trying my best to like manage it
trying not to avoid her so the new thing
now by the way because i always like to
tell you with whatever the new thing is
with my mom's dementia
the new one is now she's she she goes
how come i don't hear from you even if
even though i just talked to her
you know so now like gosh i didn't get
to i didn't call her today and i should
have but that reminds me it's like i
just have to
every single day i have to call just to
be like you know even just to hear her
say the same things over and over again
just so she gets used to that routine of
like oh i'm hearing from him every
single day
i i don't know what to i mean there's no
right or wrong way of doing any of this
you know it's just however you know if
anybody if you guys have any
suggestions or people that have dealt
with this how did you deal with it how
did you manage tell me send me you go if
you even want to tell me some of the
stories that you've gone through i'd
love to hear
that kind of stuff too even if you want
to send me a little video being like
hey like i do with real world advice
from a grown-ass man if you want to send
me a video about like
you dealing with your parents dementia
or grandparents or whoever it is in your
life if you want to tell me hey eric
this is how i did this distance this and
if you want to say anything about that
i'd love to
you can email me at eric
aarongriffin.com or you can send it to
me off on instagram
you know send it to me there it's all
good you know because it's
tough you know what i mean it's tough uh
you know and i'm trying to
not i'm trying to not avoid avoid my mom
because that's what i find myself
sometimes doing because like
just talking to her just every single
time reminds you of how it is and
you know and so you're trying to think
positive but it's just you know it's
hard you know what i mean so i know you
guys understand that
um this is a public service announcement
for all the eric griffin
fans riffing with griffin fans i've
received countless messages
and i appreciate uh you
trying to be fun some of you trying to
be funny i mean i think what people are
finding out is
doing comedy in this era of social media
it makes a lot of jokes you know old and
hacky fast
uh unoriginal because i know you a lot
of you think you're being so original
that you're the only person that has
thought of this but
i've received countless messages about
the movie soul
hey eric is this you oh you
congratulations on your movie
uh you know oh they used your likeness
did did you get paid
it's like the same joke a thousand times
okay thank you i get it
the the character sorta looks like me i
think it looks more like my buddy owen
smith than it does me but either way
you know okay
it's like enough man
you know you guys just keep going and
going and going with it it's like oh
here he is
you know oh so you know oh man i've got
so many messages on instagram about it
and everybody sends the picture they
my picture next to that picture they
found some picture of me that looks just
like that and it's just like okay guys i
get it all right so this is just
for all you out there to listen to the
podcast or watch me on
instagram or all that kind of stuff i
got it i heard the joke
thank you you know
i wanted to catch up on some things that
uh i like talking about
um you know i want to talk about
the the bachelorette finished
you know get my computer up here
you know the bat the bachelorette finish
what's her name um
tasha she picked that guy chris yeah i
just
i don't know guys to me i just reject
like once it gets down to like all these
people are sort of in love
or whatever you know it's like i didn't
like this
season of the battle it's the only time
i've ever watched a bachelorette in the
first place or a bachelor
i never watched any of them but i
watched it this time because i thought
it was kind of interesting because they
had the girl she was 39 she was super
dramatic she fell in love with some dude
dale whatever the guy's name was
right away and then they kicked her off
the show and they guys supposedly are
getting married who knows what's really
going on with them
and then you know they bring this new
girl on so all these guys were
were sort of into the other girl so now
they got again
into this new girl then you know like
then they had this dude like there's a
situation this dude was from harvard
okay
then it was like this young guy there so
the dude from harvard was like a little
older he's like 36. he's a real
snobby pretentious [ __ ] you know what
i mean that's how he came across
even though later i thought he redeemed
himself but anyway he comes across like
that there's just kind of this young guy
who's starting all this drama
clearly starting all this drama and then
you know then
he starts drama with the girl and tells
tells her like yeah
they don't they don't think that you're
making a good choice by keeping me
around
and then she comes over and be like yeah
you're questioning my
you know integrity interest it's like
yeah [ __ ] we are okay
like it it it was stupid for you to have
that guy there
yes your choices and can be
questioned on a freaking television show
where you're kissing
every single guy and telling them all
that you love them yes
your your decision making can be
questioned
being on a reality show trying to find
your husband so sorry that
you know like the whole premise is
ridiculous because
yeah you could have if you allow
yourself
it's like you're allowing yourself the
bachelor of bachelorette is just like
just open cheating it's open like
you know polyamorism it's open like hey
we're all gonna fall in love and we're
all gonna be okay under the guise
that it's a game you know that it's for
television you know
so now everybody's gonna like be okay
with
you know clearly she's kissing every
single person and i don't got a problem
with that because the bachelor the
bachelor's even
worse what they do they kiss every
single girl you know so i don't have a
problem with that what i'm just saying
though is that
you are building a connection with every
single person on the show
and as it gets lower in the smaller
smaller numbers
you're building a connection even more
and it gets stronger and stronger and
you have this real connection with like
four or five people
and then you're supposed to narrow it
down but at that point it's like it's
it's so messed up
like everybody's hurt everybody got hurt
feelings and you just kind of go
i don't know i just i i don't like it
i don't know i don't like it but it just
i just think the psychology i just
delved too deep i i think about things
too too
deeply i guess or like that go into the
nuances of it sometimes where you just
have to just enjoy
that it is what it is but for me like i
just i just started to think about like
i believe that you can connect with
anyone if you allow yourself
so the one thing about this you know
you're in this setting
and you're allowing yourself to be like
okay so i don't have to worry about
anybody's feelings
right so in that part i think it's good
because
here you are you're this guy or girl and
you're literally
it is okay for you to basically not care
about jealousy of the other people
because you go
hey you understand i i'm trying to
fall for this person too and you get it
and so and then for all the people that
are trying to go for this one person
they also get it so they're relieved of
this possessiveness feeling because they
know
oh i got to do my best so i'm the one
and they're not worried about the
other stuff so it's like in that sense
of it i like the psychology of that
but at the same time i just think it's
so
i don't know it's so damaging like it's
you know at the same time like some of
those guys were really heartbroken and
you could tell
that they opened up to this woman for
the first time in their lives or like
really deeply
and they got nothing for it in their
minds you know but i just feel like a
lot of those dudes on the bachelorette
they gonna end up being
fun i mean i'm sure there was countless
women who were like looking up their
instagrams like if she don't want you
i'll take you hey
you know what i mean because they're all
hunky in shape young dudes
it's like okay i get it so i don't know
but good luck she picked this one guy
i knew it was going to be between him it
was that guy chris i think was his name
yeah
i'm trying to look up the uh let me let
me see if i can
batch you know i'm a one-man show so i
gotta look everything up myself
bachelorette 2020. you know
yeah um yeah it was it was uh
it was an interesting i thought i
thought it was interesting but it got
once the older once the 39 year old one
got off the show
it got kind of boring to me because like
i guess that drama of it was like the
fun part
you know and then it just then it just
got really like
sort of sappy and romantic and you're
just kind of kind of going like who is
she gonna pick you know
you're wondering who she's gonna pick
because you felt like oh she has a
connection to all these people
but i feel like the connection she had
like this one guy ben
who she kicked him out already and then
he decides to come back like because
this happened twice already now the
harvard guy
got kicked out and he came back like i
love you
so she let him come back right but she
still end up kicking his ass out right
same thing with this guy ben this guy
ben is kicked out she has a romantic
night i think she has sex with all three
guys by the way
which is fine you know you want to find
out which one is what right
so she um kicks this guy ben out right
and then later
you know he's back he did the same thing
like i can't be without you and so she
gives him a chance but she still end up
kicking him out it's like
your instinct was to kick him out i
don't care if he comes back with
whatever he came back with
that he got to go right and then she
ended up picking like this
this whatever whatever the guy and so i
don't know
maybe you guys don't care about what i'm
saying right now but the bachelor is
just a weird
psychological experiment and which
brings me to um
there's a show i started watching i
gotta look it up yeah
it's called are you the one and it's on
mtv
and i've never seen it before so it was
on netflix right
and i'm watching it and it looked kind
of it was weird how it looks i was like
wow this is kind of
the style seems weird i wonder why
they're doing this but then i looked it
up and it was like oh it's from 2014.
it's the old show
but i love this show guys this is why i
want to talk about it on the podcast i
don't know if you've ever watched
are you the one but it's okay let me
just go over it it's a show on mtv so
this is what it's about
they get 10 guys and they get 10 girls
and they they put them through a
rigorous
matchmaking process so it's probably
like eharmony where they ask him a
thousand questions or a hundred [ __ ] you
know they ask him a bunch of questions
they do a psychological survey they find
out
they they have this sort of say say a
psychological algorithm
per se right that they have and they
match the people up
they they determine of these 20 people
these are the best match-ups based off
science you know based off you know
psychology and science right
and then they say so the game is these
20 people have to figure out who the
perfect matches are
they have 10 chances and if they get it
right on the 10 on the 10th chance
they all win they split a million
dollars so everybody gets 50
000 each okay
i love that that i love that part of it
because it's like what's your motivation
is your motivation love
or is your motivation money so now you
can get both so we could find
we could find love that is that is
destined to match
or it just it works based off
personality and all these things
and you get 50 000 100 000 as a couple
that's great right so
you start with that premise but what
they found is a bunch of broken
people who are terrible at relationships
and also people in their 20s
who are so dumb like these kids
are so stupid and that's
where the drama comes in so you're
watching the show so initially the
people come in the house right
so they come in the house and and they
see each other now
and this is what i love about the show
this is that nuanced stuff that i like
the psychological part of it right
because
we don't pick people for the right
reasons
initially and this is what's happening
you know you hear people going like well
that guy's usually my type the girl's
like well he's got tattoos he's the bad
boy or
there's this guy over here oh that's my
type so everybody's picking their sexual
attraction
first i test they go i like how that
person looks
that's what i want so they all match up
they all pick now they have this
ceremony right
where one week the guys picked the girls
they think is their match the other
next week the girls pick the guys
whatever so then they're all sitting
here
they're all coupled up and matched up
and then the host is like okay here
there's ten lights they had these ten
like
you know movie theater spotlights that
shoot up into the sky
and if if okay so the couples are
sitting there
and so for every match a light lights up
you know what i mean
so they have the matches everybody's
sitting there and then maybe they get
like two lights
so of all these couples only there's
only two matches
so when you see that you already know
you're sitting next to somebody who most
likely is not your match
even though in your head you've gone
through all this [ __ ] of like oh
this is my match
and so you would think and this is why
you i guess you have to have young
people young
just arrogant dumb you know they just
they don't have any there's no
wherewithal it's just all they feel like
they're invincible you know when you're
in your 20s man you think you could do
anything like
that you think you're so smart you know
what i mean
and then you just like you know so they
have all these kids right they're there
so then so initially here's what happens
in the first week
all of a sudden they all coupled up and
this is the love of their life
i don't want to leave this person you
know you know you know you do that thing
where you just meet somebody you start
talking to them and you feel like oh my
god this is the connection of a lifetime
because that's how you do it you know
and then of course they have this place
called the boom boom room
in there this private room where
everybody goes to have sex with whoever
so people having sex on the first night
you know it's all this stuff and so now
everybody's all coupled up and then like
so they're sitting there so in the first
season
you know they're figuring out like oh we
didn't do this right
one of the people has a strategy you
know one of the people's like look
let's figure out this is about the money
he's like okay so
it didn't work so let's mix and match
let's figure out you know but then
there's people who are like
that this one girl name was brittany and
part of me feels like it's scripted like
there's writers pushing them egging them
on to do things
i hate thinking like that but i'm sure
that's the case but
i like to believe that these people are
just dumb you know what i mean
so this girl she falls she's like
obsessed with this one guy
and she keeps going he's my match i know
he's my match and she's just being
stubborn about it
and i'm just looking at these people and
i'm thinking myself damn
a million dollars is online and y'all
not gonna work together at all
i mean it just shows you how difficult
it is to get people to come together
to like even to work towards a common
goal because by the way
even if like this computer psychology
and all this stuff
has put you like this is your match it
don't mean you got to stay with this
person
let's just do this for now and get this
money i'm looking at the show like [ __ ]
shut up
like just find another dude so you could
get the match y'all can get the money
and then when you leave this place you
and that guy who you think is the one
you all can just be together for you
know the you know another week when you
realize that he's not doing
your match or you go oh you you beat the
odds and the guy is your match right
no they're just acting up fighting being
selfish
and i just go damn this is the real
the the show part of it is like it's
such a psychological experiment
of showing people you think you know
but you just don't know the reasons why
you get with someone
i mean initially they're so superficial
they're so
even when you have what you think is
some oh i have instant chemistry or
whatever it is like that
that doesn't necessarily mean that that
it's going to
work or that you're compatible you know
it's weird how sexual attraction
that thing that you have it actually
it actually is it's mutual it's not
mutually exclusive to
the things that like make a relationship
work you know like if are you neat
are you are you messy or you know do you
like to travel
are you outdoorsy are you organized
person are you like
a go-getter are you a motivator you know
how do you guys click there's so many
different aspects of that we really
don't even
think about when we are initially trying
to meet someone it's all so
primal it's also like i want you because
i want you i desire you or whatever that
is but that does not sustain a
relationship
and so and so watching this show it's
like the young people that watch this
show
i hope that they suck because it's still
going on they had a you know
it's been going on they have a 2019
season so i didn't even know that i
don't watch mtv
anymore you know what i mean i'm a whole
fart so but i
really love this show because like i
said i love the experiment of it so
you know you would think that the people
watching the show would be like oh well
so maybe
i shouldn't just go gung-ho because i
have a feeling about
someone right because it actually you
might be missing out on
a real connection a real match even if
it turns into like a powerful friendship
you know you really should give yourself
that opportunity to look past
your superficial wants and desires you
know but we all say the same thing in a
relationship well i have to be sexually
attracted to them
but i would think that all those things
that make a relationship
click or the things that make you
compatible with someone
all those things lead up to actually
being sexually compatible
you know but who knows because maybe
that gets messed up too but
i think it goes hand in hand because by
the way i mean
you literally can be sexually attracted
to anyone
if you allow yourself but a lot of times
we we all have a recipe
you know like we have a cookbook you
know in our cookbook it's like uh you
know
big titties or whatever whatever your
thing is you know girls would be like
he's got to have abs or
or if you like oh he's got to be this so
he's got to be that and
we have this recipe and we think this is
the only recipe
that we can follow but i just don't
think it works like that i think it's
more
it's more improved really that you know
when you
you you start to connect with someone
and then the ingredients start to come
together and it starts to flow into
something that you didn't know
was there but we just often times don't
allow ourselves
to really explore that because of these
preconceived ideas we have in our head
about
what we think is our match
so are you the one you know i do
recommend watching it just because i
like to hate watch it too
because again it's people in their 20s
for real being super stupid
it's the only way i could like it's like
i look at that
you know and it's the times i feel like
oh like i understand
i understand i'm closer to being an
old person than i am to being a person
in their 20s you know i feel like that's
where i'm at in my life
so i look at that and i go damn was i
this arrogant or was i this
dumb was i this like naive
you know did i did i have this like
weird lens
of looking at the world because i was a
certain age
you know it's ah man it's it's really
it's really interesting
to watch and then i'm watching season
two and there's like this real southern
girl but she's a little chubby
this little chubby southern girl she got
great personality she's fun she talked
with a real
thick accent you know and she's like
into this like frat boy this frat boy
you know and he's just not into her
but they got a connection you know like
you could tell that they
like but for him it's just friendship
and she don't get it
but i'm looking at it i'm going look at
the girls that he keeps going for
like if you don't understand it you're
not that type
right and you you know you got to see
that like he you're not his
type but like at the same time
all that i've been saying is they
actually could end up
really having of the the best connection
and that best connection even could turn
into being like
a really great sexual connection but
like i say we don't allow ourselves
we don't allow ourselves sometimes to to
really
explore that we don't really allow
ourselves to explore that
because we're so caught up on i like
people to look
like this and i will only let myself
fall for people that look
like this and if they don't look like
that then they're not my match
oh man i don't know you know and
sometimes
sometimes you do have that thing where
you have like this sort of like
chemical connection you know one time i
was at greenblatt's
deli this was a while ago you know it
was late i just got off the lab factory
stage
and i was it was late i was gonna get a
sandwich and go home and this like girl
comes in
and she's like the delivery she's like
picking up ubereats you know
and she was like she was younger than me
and we started talking
like i just was being like hey you know
it was a casual talk like yeah whatever
but there was a thing there you know
it was really weird you know what i mean
it was real
it was really weird you know uh
i i can't explain it you know and
i could tell that something could have
happened
if i had pursued it right
but i just it just didn't seem
appropriate at the time or whatever
whatever the circumstances was
it was and i always thought about it
because i was like damn there was
something
because she looked at me and i looked at
her in a way that i was like what the
[ __ ] you know
and and sometimes that just happens
you know and then you eventually get to
pursue that
you know but it doesn't mean that that
thing is like
the that thing is right for you you know
but we i think we all look for that
you know i remember the first time i met
rachel we were
she was i was on stage because she came
to my show
and then i i was doing my act and i
looked out and i
saw her you know and then we were like
and i was doing my comedy and i was
performing for her
the things i was saying was for her and
instantly as i was looking down at her
i was like uh yeah there's something
here
and and was it all like
was it all because of the circumstances
of being me knowing she's coming to the
show
and you know i how we met online and
and all this and you know so as all that
goes into the
into the soup you know into the recipe
and it made something well yeah maybe it
did because
here we are right now engaged and living
together and all that right
so and you know think about it for
yourselves send me a message in the
comments have you ever had like some
kind of like just
weird reaction uh not even weird just
like where you know
you you met someone and you were like oh
man we we there's something here
you wonder what that is is there is
there some chemical coming off of you
and coming off that person and it's
connecting
is it all mental is it all like you know
is it all fufu magic
you know or is it like or is there
really something
like if you had like different kind of
lenses in your eyes that could like
show like the spectral plane or
something and then like
our auras really do connect and
you know or when two auras touch and and
they have
similar things you could feel it i mean
i don't know
because i think i've felt that a few
times in my life but it doesn't mean
that
that person is you know the one
sometimes you just
find the one uh but i don't think
there's just one
there's just that one that time because
of what's going on
but anyways i do recommend
watching are you the one just to like
really
you know if you're older look back and
be like damn i remember when i was just
stupid
or if you were you know you just like
these types of shows
this is one of those ones that's like
super fascinating and interesting to uh
to get into so i really liked it
what's up guys is eric griffin i want to
talk to you once again about helix
sleep i'm a side sleeper i don't know
about you
i can't sleep on my back i get so
uncomfortable i don't sleep with my
stomach i can't breathe so i sleep on my
side and when you have a hard lumpy ass
mattress
it can hurt your shoulder your fingers
get numb
that's what was happened to me in my old
mattress until i got a helix
sleep mattress now we all have different
reasons why we can't sleep
you know the politics the pandemic
whatever's going on in your love life
just anxiety whatever it is
a good night's sleep is one of the most
important things for the
for better health so i got a helix sleep
mattress and i'm recommending
for you guys to get a helix sleep
mattress uh you know the best thing
about it is they got this sleep quiz to
help you find out
what kind of mattress you need for you
uh it's a two-minute quiz
it matches your body type and sleep
preference to the perfect mattress for
you
everybody's unique everybody's got
different styles like i said i sleep on
my side so
whatever is good for you if you're a hot
sleeper
you know do you sweat at night or are
you a heavy person they have a mattress
that will fit
any body type and it that's the best
thing about it
just having that sleep quiz to help you
figure out like
oh this i need it to be soft or hard or
medium
like that's the kind of thing you don't
think about when you go to the mattress
store and you like what do you do you
have to lay down in the bed
it's all the same and that's not even
necessarily going to be the bed that's
going to be right for you it's just like
oh one of the mattresses that they
probably have in the back
this one is like completely matched and
perfect for
your unique body style like i like i
said i took the sleep kids sleep quiz
and i got a midnight lux
which is perfect for side sleeping it's
just i'm telling you
you don't even think about it because a
mattress is one of those things that you
get that you go
oh well this is just thing that i have
and i'm stuck with it so
if you're going to be stuck with it at
least be stuck with something that
you're going to enjoy and really take
advantage of right so if you're looking
for a mattress take the quiz you order
your mattress
it's matched to you and it comes shipped
right to your door
and you know it comes in it's crazy
because it comes in this like really
tight
compressed box you know you wouldn't
think that a king-size mattress would be
in the box that it's in
you open that sucker up and you know it
explodes out you let it sit
then it it unfolds and it's perfect for
for um
it's perfect for you you know for the
it's gonna be the best sleep of your
life i guarantee you
they have a 10 year warranty so you get
to try it for 100 nights
risk free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't like it but i'm telling
you
you're gonna like it all right helix is
offering up to 200
off on all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
griffin so make sure you get that guys
helixsleep.com
griffin it's very important go take
your two-minute sleep quiz get your
mattress
and have like i said the best sleep of
your life
let's get back to the show that's my
review of that
bachelorette are you the one all right
more serious topic is
you know let me get my ipad out again
i want you guys if you go to google if
you're listening
to the podcast or you're watching
whatever open up another
thing on your podcast and i just want
you to look up something
that 50
of healthcare workers
don't want vaccine
all right and then
you'll see like so many articles
about this there's so many articles
about it
from all over the place the uk
everywhere
like there's this article what daily
mail just
just this is one of them that came up
you know it says
um you know wait
so these you know you go to these things
these stupid ads it's like get this
freaking ad off the screen this one says
nearly 40 percent of health care workers
say it's not likely they will get a
coronavis vaccine
because they are too afraid of the jabs
were developed too quickly to be safe
this is so many articles like this there
are so many articles about health care
workers
it's like 50 60 of health care workers
in this state in that state
are not going to take it now i've talked
about this on the podcast about the
vaccine i always go hey i'll take the
vaccine you know vaccines are safe
you know for the most part you know it's
like you know when people talk
i've gotten messages about the vaccine
and people are talking about like
you know this happened to this person
this happened to that person okay listen
a vaccine i like it
to like insulin say there are people who
are allergic to insulin
but just because there are people who
are allergic
it doesn't take away the merits and the
benefit
of what insulin is and what it does for
most people
it's just like think of it this way a
condom even a condom let's say
you know you're allergic to latex but
just because
you're allergic to latex it doesn't mean
condoms are bad
it's just you're allergic to latex so
there are going to be people that have
as
adverse reactions to vaccines
but just because there are those people
it doesn't mean what the vaccine is
supposed to do
it's bad or that it inherently it's
something wrong with it
right that's how i feel about that but i
gotta say
that being said when so many healthcare
workers are saying
they don't want to take it it makes you
go what
are you talking about because this is
like
look if you go to a restaurant and
the chef made some special soup
and none of the employees want to eat it
you're going to be like what's wrong
with the soup because
who knows about the soup more than the
people that work at that restaurant
they might if they come to you being
like well i think the chef
you know he rushed through this uh this
soup
usually supposed to simmer for eight
hours
he did it in two hours i don't think
it's gonna taste right
i mean you would be like well i don't
know if i want the soup you know what i
mean
that's how i feel about the vaccine
right now i'm a little bit like
how come these uh workers don't want to
take it
because they're in the medical field so
i saw a wonderful article and it was
said it was like
you know they think it's too politicized
they think they rushed it because it
you know it's politics made them rush
and so they
they're afraid they didn't do a good
enough job because vaccines normally
take this amount of time
i mean that's valid right that's a valid
feeling that's a
way for you to be like to give you some
pause
but devil's advocate on that point for
me
is the whole world is affected by this
the entire world the co the entirety of
the
the whole planet science team was
working on this at the same time
so i'm okay with
all of the scientists in the world you
know
or who you know all the experts in this
field we're all working on this
yeah i think they can take a year
instead of four
because everybody's resources were being
put into this because
it was going to save the planet so
i want to think like that but i'm sure
some of you out there
are feeling a little bit like what's
going on here
right because i get i get messages about
these things that i talk about
people you know some of them are rude
some people just you know they just they
like hearing themselves
they just i don't know why you have to
approach someone
in such a rude manner when if you're
just trying to engage in
a conversation and back and forth you
know i don't care if you disagree with
me
great if you disagree with me start a
dialogue you can come into my comments
and be like
well i actually i think that this is
where i disagree with you and this is
why
and give me some other points but no
some of these people
you're such an idiot blah blah blah
idiot
this is dumb but it's like why are you
talking to me like that you don't know
me like that you know what i mean
it's like i want to hear your point
but not if you're an [ __ ] you know
what i mean so anyways
this is what that this is one of those
things i'm saying like it's like
you might be out there feeling like this
is how i feel about the vaccine
do you feel like it's safe you know
does it worry you that so many health
care workers
don't want to take it and and also like
you know you just look up
sometimes i like to look up let me go
back to the ipad
i keep the ipad handy it's like some of
the times i like
i like to just know what's going on with
certain things
so you know it's like it's like if you
look up i'll look up
you know covet news
you just go into you know you go covet
news
and then it's like you see all these
things and it takes you down a rabbit
hole
you know when you just look at the the
titles you know fouchy is back in the
news
it says without she pushes back on trump
covet death numbers are
real you know so then you go into that
and you find out like
like what is trump saying about it but
what's this source
what's this news source so when you look
we like when i look up things i like to
look it up like that
because then you kind of get a sense by
looking at all the titles and seeing
where it comes came from
you kind of see what slant it has and i
hate that the news is like that but
it is what it is that's the world that
we live in you know
so yeah and then when you look up covet
news man
it it's like it's all negative man it's
just
there's no good news about it at
all there's no hopeful news man i i keep
trying to look for something where i go
oh man this we're it's all about
you know florida reports ten thousand
new cases
uh you know what i mean that's this is
all that it is you know
um u.s deaths at 350 000
uh you know it's like you know they just
they're just bombarding us with this
like
really negative like information it's
like it's very scary if you just look at
this stuff
like this is where we're supposed to get
our news this is where our information
is coming from a place like google and
and how google is compiling all the
information from all these different
places cnn
la times washington post cbs news mpr
you know like the npr like npr seems to
be like
one of those places that you you think
okay i think they're doing some real
down the middle news but it's like
covid 19 cases surge in u.s as
vaccinations fall below government
predictions you know it's like
you read that and you go oh my god
what's going on like are we gonna get
better
so i don't know man
you know i feel like i've been like
talking about oh i still need my
ipad for the next part you know i i feel
like we
you know we we keep talking about this
and everybody has their own thoughts
about this nana it's just
you know i i was really feeling a
certain way because like i said we came
into the new year
2021 but it didn't feel like a
celebration it didn't feel it just feels
like more of the same
if not worse so it's hard to like you
want to feel hopeful
and that's what the new year is all
about you know you get to the new year
you want to feel like
we could do it we can make it this is an
all new me i'm going to start working
out i'm going to change my life we start
to think about all these things
and then we end up you know and then we
end up you know falling short or
succeeding or whatever it is but we have
it's a sort of a hopeful feel
but like right now i feel like how was
how was
december 31st 350 000 people were dead
and the vaccines going slow and the
election is still weird and
and then you know january 1st what's
different nothing
it's all the same like the virus is not
going to go all right let me give you
guys a break because it's a new year
let me stretch my legs and start over no
it's like
you know so it's sometimes it's actually
to me
even more depressing you know because
you're like damn i thought this was
gonna be this is supposed to be a new
time but
that being said
i hope that all i can be is hopeful that
the vaccine works the numbers come down
and we can get back to normal and it's
like whatever that means
i was watching my girl was watching uh
rachel was watching
um this ariana grande
netflix documentary concert thing
and they're showing her concert footage
and i was looking at it and i was like
wow
will we ever see that again when's the
next time we're gonna see
like 25 000 people
in this big huge space
all crammed together communing
through art just you know
just seeing all the lights and people
taking pictures and
people singing and really feeling moved
by their
favorite artists that they can't they
paid money to go see and
like how like are we gonna experience
that again
and that's why i try to feel hopeful
that
because we need that we need it
you know on my small level it's like
when people come
to a comedy club and
you know they're all sitting there and
laughing as a community
just everybody is like coming together
through this person on stages
references and and humor and and
sensibility and they're bringing it all
together and making a group of strangers
laugh in unison man there's nothing like
it
we need that i miss it i want to see it
again
so i just even with all the negative
news and
all the just terrible stories that you
hear
and all the things that are going on
with this election and
you know is you know is binding gonna
you know is he even gonna be able
is he even gonna get in office so you
know with everything
all that stuff that's going on all i
could do is be hopeful that
this vaccine is gonna work and we're
gonna beat this thing
and get freaking back to normal
that's my hope all right
[Music]
now i want to finish out talking about
this new show that i really
really like okay i want to look i want
to get the
i want to get the uh information right
so we're going to the ipad again
um here we go all right it's called
raised by wolves
and it's on hbo max
it's a science fiction drama
uh it you know the first two episodes
were directed by ridley scott really
scott made aliens
you know right he made aliens right he's
like yeah
yeah yeah yeah he made original alien
and he made aliens
with sigourney weaver so he loves this
kind of sci-fi fantasy stuff
man this show is so bizarre
it is just so bizarre so it's one of
these like post-apocalyptic
you know you know they love to do sci-fi
movies where human beings have ruined
the planet
you know like this george clooney movie
on netflix which was
like what a snooze fest but anyway i'll
talk about that movie another time
but raised by will so it's like this
post-apocalyptic
you know the world has been ravaged by
we ruined it right and we ruined it with
religion too
which is one of the things i find
fascinating about is like the religious
wars so it's like the atheist verse the
religious people and
they've decimated the planet and now
we're
out here trying to you know we're trying
to live in space
you know because we've just ruined earth
and
technology's so advanced that they have
these sort of like realistic androids
so though the show starts off with these
two androids landing
landing on this sort of wasteland planet
and these two androids have to
recolonize
so they have human embryos and this
certain
robot is designed to be able to
uh not give birth but sort of
you know they have like these little
room machines and
they're hooked up to this to this
android and the android
gives birth helps raise these like seven
kids and it's like two androids and one
of the androids
was it's like the terminator
like she's like a terminator like a
killing machine
she was used by one side to like
decimate she's powerful she can fly
and she screams like ah and it like
makes people explode
this her creator or some the
person that took her over like
reprogrammed her to be a caregiver
so and it's her and this sort of like
service robot
you know i don't you know she this
robot's white the other robot's black
i don't know why they made that choice
that the service robot had to be black
[Laughter]
i didn't even think about it till right
now it's just like it's like any attempt
to like make diversity so you make the
robot like i don't even know why you
would even
have a have a robot have a race in the
first place
you know but it's like what race would
you pick i mean it's just a weird choice
right but anyways
so they're like she's called mother and
he's called father and they're raising
these kids
you know and then some stuff happens you
know and then like
you know um the uh
the other side the the religious ones
the zealots the religious
they have their ships and they're coming
to this planet too and it's just how
the whole thing comes about like how
they interact with
the new people that they're in war with
and then there was like
i'm not ex i don't reason why i'm being
vague because i don't want to give
anything away
but i just will say that it was such a
it's such a it's such a really
interesting show if you like sci-fi
fantasy stuff
man this this is the show man
you know it's just so it's so crazy to
see
you know like how they you know you you
to believe that
these robots are like under like they
have ai you know what i mean
they're they're they're figuring out how
to have feelings and
they're raising these kids and you know
and then like the bad people come and
she like destroys the ship
and then kidnaps some some of the kids
on the ship
you know because her own a lot of her
own kids that they
she gave help to give birth to died then
you find out they died because there's
they're eating food on the planet that's
radioactive i mean it's like a whole
thing man but it's like such a
it's such a like fascinating
drama i couldn't stop watching it yeah
the performances are great
you know the people the two people
playing the robots you
they're doing such a great job you but
you actually believe that they are
robots
just the special effects are good and
you know really scott's great you know
he's uh
i don't know if he ever topped alien
alien and aliens i think those were like
the cream of the crop in terms of like
80s 90s sci-fi action movies
but this is just one of those really uh
bizarre shows that i
i think you guys should uh take a look
at
raised by wolves it's on hbo max or if
you have hbo
i switched i had cable for a while i had
a spectrum
i'm one that i was one of the very one
of the few
you know i think i was paying too much
money for all this stuff man because i
had spectrum but at the same time i
still had hulu disney plus
netflix dc universe you know i had all
these things
so i moved to this new place and
spectrum dropped the ball in this
building so they weren't allowed
to to put their things in this building
so i couldn't get spectrum
so then but the internet is like super
fast like the internet here is great
it's
frontier i'm not getting any money from
these people i'm just letting you know i
have frontier communications
great internet is so fast 500 upload 500
download right
so then i said well let me try one of
these
streaming services so i got youtube tv
man i got to tell you i don't know what
you got if you if you still got cable
you might want to switch over to any one
of these sling
like there's so many there's five or six
of them now and they all do the same
thing they all got
contracts with all the companies and
they're all doing the same thing they
offer all the channels
so i'm still watching all the channels
that i wanted to watch
because the one i really wanted to have
is nfl red zone
now not all of them offer nfl red zone
but youtube
tv offers you a referral red zone and
which i love is the dvr you can record
as many shows as you want so i haven't
even seen the difference because i used
to record like i love the sports talk
show host
the sports talk show so i would listen
to like first take and speak for
yourself on fox
i would listen i would watch all these
shows regularly
you know what i mean i would record them
so now
you could just record watch wherever you
want you could have up to six family
members i mean i know this sounds like a
commercial but i'm just telling you
if you still got cable i would really i
would i tell you man you should really
think about
getting rid of it and just going to like
if you have a smart tv you are ready to
go
try it for free you could do it for free
and that [ __ ] is
dope i'm watching everything i would
watch before
right there i have apple and then
so i have two smart tvs i've won a
living room one in the bedroom right
and so but i have apple tv because
everything i have is apple so
i wanted to have so i have apple tv
rachel loves the apple tv because you
could just send it from your computer
right to the
you know whatever you're doing so i
thought oh i need to get a second apple
tv to go into the living room
but before i did that i bought it and
then but i said well let me hook up the
tv first
so i hooked up the tv i have a samsung
tv and it has all the apps on it
and i was like well wait a minute it has
youtube tv it has a
nba it has uh netflix hulu
disney plus it has all the things that i
would want and i was like well maybe let
me see how this works tried it for a few
days
and i was like i don't even need this i
sent that i took that apple tv back
because the smart tv is good enough so
if you got a smart tv and even if you
don't have a smart tv all you need
really is
a fire stick a chrome you know google
chrome or whatever that is it called
google chrome yeah with google con
google cast or whatever that cast thing
is
a fire like i said a fire stick or any
kind of thing that strong kind of
streaming thing a roku
anything like that you just hook it up
to your tv you got the internet
get one of these streaming services like
sling youtube tv
uh there's a bunch of other ones just
look them up and it's totally worth it
man
and it's way cheaper than cable like my
bill is so much cheaper now it's
ridiculous
so that's my uh commercial for that that
i'm not getting any money for
but anyways i got a lot um coming up for
the 20 20 21 i am gonna have guests i
have a whole new setup
i'm gonna i'm gonna change to the
background but i you know i brought it
with me and i just put this one up but
i think i should change it and i have
like you know i have some great art that
people made for me you know
i'm trying to put all my stuff up that
people brought i had this great picture
you can't really see it because the guy
sent it in like cardboard and it's all
it got kind of messed up in the mail but
i hope that guy still watches but he
sent me this painting he made
it's like a black with like this blue
dot you know
i don't know what it means you know
everybody has their own art
and i got my stuff that i have up here
you know i got my great blake griffin
bobblehead
i got this great riffing with griffin
slime that used to be right there like i
said i got this great painting
i got my hangover candles you know my
ugly truth dvd which you can get on my
uh
website you know i got my workaholics
dvds
you know i got me when i was in high
school looking all svelte
you know so we were trying to make it
happen and if you guys think of some
guests that you'd want me to have
on the podcast but you know put it in
the comments tell me hey
i like i like to interact with you guys
too so if you say hey try to get this
person on the podcast or
hey can you talk about this this and
this or what do you think about this
show this movie or that kind of stuff
i'm gonna you know do uh more of that
you know of course i'm gonna have rachel
on too she'll probably be my first guest
again and we'll
hear and i will recap everything that's
going on
leading up to the new year but anyways i
really appreciate you guys
watching and listening to riffing with
griffin
i love being here i love doing this and
make sure you catch me
gaming i game every day on twitch at
error griffin gaming
so i'm still doing that and then the the
potluck is over i did this great show on
twitch
on the crown channel called potluck i
think you can see replays of those
on youtube on the crown channel but we
had i had a good time doing that so i'm
still out there i'm still out here
trying to like make things happen in
2021 uh but a lot of online stuff too
i've really been delving into the online
world with twitch and
gaming and playing call of duty i've
always put up with my awards on clips
but
look that's all we're going to do for
this week uh once again i appreciate you
listening watching sharing subscribing
all that great stuff and i will see you
next week
you